so I'm freshman in high school and I'm
walking through the hallway and this
teacher is like an admin of some kind
walks out of his office and he's like
son you work out that teacher Mr gibons
ended up working out with me every day
in high school and showed me how to work
out he probably saw on some level that I
was some angsty teenager that felt angry
about whatever and during our workout
sessions I was like man I'm going to
come back at our 10-year reunion and I
was like I'm going to show him I was
like he's going to be working for me
he's like no he's not he's like and
you're not going to do that not if I
have anything to say about it because if
you come back at a 10-year reunion and
say hey John everything I have look at
me now the guy's going to laugh and be
like you did all of this to try and
prove me wrong I feel sorry for you he
was like the only thing that you can do
is win so big that all of them
constantly compare themselves to you and
then you'll forget they exist